[MUSIC PLAYING]
JONATHAN ROCHELLE:
Welcome, everybody.
It's really late, I know so
we're just going to cancel.
No I'm just kidding.
But I've never-- I don't
think in my life I've ever
used a lectern, but
this late I think
I'm going to be like
this the whole time.
Is that all right?
I'm really tired.
But I'm so excited about this
topic that I will re-energize.
I'm going to talk about
machine learning and learning
technology, and just a
pre-warning in case some of you
would rather just start
going out for drinks,
I'm not going to teach you
about machine learning per se.
I'm not a machine
learning expert,
but I have some
thoughts and some ideas
on how machine learning connects
to learning, human learning
that I wanted to share.
And you will hopefully
learn a little bit
about machine learning if
you don't know much about it.
There's a little bit there.
I manage Google Apps
for Education right now,
and that's what really
gets me into this topic.
And I like people to
know me as I see myself.
So I like to share
pictures that I have
in my head when I had hair.
That's me before my
interview for my first job
that I did not get.
And that's my Toyota Celica in
the background, which I still
love to this day.
I don't have it anymore.
But I'm a product
manager at Google.
I co-founded Google
Docs and Drive.
I was part of the original
team that did that.
That was 11 and 1/2 years ago.
I started in 2005 at Google.
And now I manage G
Suite for Education
and the Jamboard product, which
you might have seen earlier.
I'm also a school board member,
probably the hardest job
I've ever taken on.
I knew I was taking on a job
that I might regret when,
instead of congratulating
me, my neighbors thanked me,
because that's really
the kind of job it is.
Nobody wants it.
And most importantly, I'm
the father of three students.
And I think this is what
motivates me the most.
This is what drives me to
care so much, so deeply
about education and improving
it, and applying technology
in a way that is
meaningful for the learner,
not for the technology.
And so my learning
values, I would say,
are in three main areas,
things that I really feel.
First, creativity--
creativity, I think,
is just the basis for so
much and so many things
that we should learn
and should teach.
Discovery of passion--
I feel like it's every
educator's responsibility
to help kids discover what
they might be excited about.
It's also every
person's responsibility
and every parent's
responsibility
to do that for their
children or themselves.
And learning through
engagement-- something that
is actually I would
say more possible now,
but always difficult because
engagement for one person
is different than the next.
So I want to step back and look
at collaboration because that's
where we made some advances in
the products that I worked on.
And there is a bit
of an analogy here,
but collaboration 10
years ago could probably
be described as the following.
First of all, it was
incredibly painful.
To work together was hard.
There was incredible fear about
what if I lost this thing?
I'm working for an hour on my
machine, and I lost it, right?
My hard drive crashes.
And that is followed by
sadness when it does happen
and perhaps anger.
And then, of course, you go
through the many stages of--
and denial is always there.
And I love to look
at this model and say
it's very similar in education.
There is so much of this
that happens in education,
these models that we deny
perhaps the things that
are wrong with it because
it's actually pretty good,
and it's better than it was.
So when we got personal
productivity tools
they were so much better that we
lived with them for very long.
And so when we started
the Docs efforts,
we were going after
something that we
felt was very
important, and that
was the collaboration side.
So we took something
like spreadsheets,
and that's where it started.
And we said yeah, it's great.
Spreadsheets are amazing.
Personal productivity tools were
so powerful, are so powerful,
but what was painful and
frustrating was the sharing.
And so we went after that.
And so we delivered
something that wasn't just
spreadsheets on the
web, but we delivered
something that was shared
spreadsheets on the web.
We added that-- We basically
tweaked two features.
We added the share button.
And more importantly, we
took away the save button.
We like to say we killed the
save button because there's
no reason for us to have to
take that other mundane step
of saving when there's that
risk, that fear that you're
going to lose what you have.
So we just looked at
something that was great,
and we tried to make it better.
And this is what we ended
up with in Docs, something
that you're actually
collaborating on
at the same time.
So getting to G Suite,
these are the products
that I was involved
in from that time.
I had a small company
that was acquired.
There was another company
acquired called Writely.
And we built these products up--
Spreadsheets, Docs,
Slides, Forms.
And we were going after that
problem of collaboration.
And over that time, a
tremendous number of educators
found what they would
call magic in those tools
because of how they
did things differently
that suddenly
transformed them into not
being personal productivity
tools, but being learning
tools--
and most importantly
because they
were able to give
students fast feedback
and they were able to let
students work together.
That wasn't what we expected
when we built the tools,
but that's what happened.
And about four years ago, I
changed what I did and stopped
managing Docs and
Drive and moved over
to Google Apps for
Education and to move over
to try to build new
productivity tools.
And that's when we launched
Google Classroom and Google
Expeditions, the VR tool
that's used in classrooms,
and Jamboard.
So that was my involvement.
So you look at what's
gone on in technology.
You now have the
world's information.
It's at your fingertips.
It's literally at your
fingertips on your phone.
It's even-- perhaps
you don't even
need something on your
fingertips to do it, right?
You just use your voice.
And you get what you need.
You get the answers.
The answers are all there--
the world's information.
And then you add
something like Drive,
or any product like
that, and now you
have all of your information.
So you have the
world's information
and your information
accessible and useful.
Now what?
OK, that's all there.
When you think about what
at least I did in school
is I learned by
memorizing some of that.
The world's information
I'm memorizing.
I'm working on memorizing, and
my kids still the 50 states'
capitals in the United States.
I don't know why my kids are
memorizing the 50 states'
capitals.
I really have no idea.
Because they can walk into my
kitchen and say OK, Google--
oh, sorry if your
phones all light up--
what's the capital of Nebraska?
I know it's Lincoln, by the
way, because I was taught that.
So we have that.
But now what?
How do we get to the
self-driving car of education?
How do we make it so
we take that next leap?
What should our students learn--
facts and previously
known algorithms
and how to do that rote step
to do, say, long division?
Or should they learn
problem-solving skills
and tools for problem
solving to improve life,
to actually discover and
create new things, to invent?
Now learning, has it changed?
When you look at
how learning has
changed, I want to
step back and say,
well, what kind of learning?
Machine learning
versus human learning--
how has learning changed
in those two areas?
So let's look at
machine learning.
Let's see if we can learn
something from that.
So computers are great at
following instructions.
It's what turned
me on to computing,
to computer science, when I
was a junior in high school.
Absolutely fell in love within
two days of a computer class--
the called it "computer
math" back then--
because I realized
that the computer would
do whatever I said.
I could figure out how
to give it a command,
and it would do it.
It would carry it out.
And computers are
just great at that.
You tell it what to
do, and it does it.
And that's great.
Computers are good
at doing math.
You can just ask it a question,
and it'll give you an answer.
That's just what it does, right?
That's what the computers do.
And remembering facts--
it's got every fact.
And I say computers lightly.
There's an easy way to get
any fact from the internet.
And repetitive tasks--
give it something
repetitive and mundane.
The computer will eat it up--
humans not so much.
They'll do it, but
they won't like it.
Or most people-- some people do
actually like repetitive tasks.
That's OK.
And then we made
computers more powerful.
You add speed and data capacity.
And over the last couple
of decades, data collection
and machine learning
specialization,
a miniaturization in cooling
and power consumption.
All those things
came together for us
to take a leap in computing.
And that leap was
actually quite noticeable.
And then humans were able
to teach computers because
of that power to do things
like recognize patterns
and classify data.
It's why we can point our phones
at a sign in another language
and get an immediate
translation.
You can do that today,
and it's amazing.
And it's natural now, the
power we have in our hands
in our phones because
of that miniaturization.
And the power and the computing,
in conjunction with the cloud,
gives us that.
And we can take
advantage of that.
Clustering data,
predicting values,
ranking relevance--
there's so many things
that we were able to
teach computers to do
because the power was there.
And so when you look at machine
learning, there are two models.
And I'm using
something lightly here
so don't worry
about the semantics
of "artificial intelligence."
But certainly we called
it artificial intelligence
for many decades.
And that's basically making
machines "intelligent"
by giving them facts
and letting them
be able to make the next step
by saying, if this, then that.
Machine learning is making
machines that learn.
And you could still call that
artificial intelligence, which
is why I'm saying don't
worry about the semantics.
But those are the two
modes of machine learning.
But if you look at
these two things
and you want to compare
them, the old way,
what I'm calling AI
here even though you
can say AI is everything,
is just basically
saying, if then else,
but so many times
that a human could never do it.
So if this pattern exists,
then do this, else.
Does this pattern exist?
Then do this, else.
If this pattern exists--
and it just looks for thousands
and thousands or millions
of patterns and
is able to mimic.
And that's what I would
call an expert system.
And that is the old way.
That's the way we used to
think about making computers
intelligent.
It's the best thing we had.
And the new way, the
machine learning way,
is much more about writing
computer programs that
learn from examples--
so trying to classify
data, classify emails.
So it actually modifies itself
based on patterns it sees,
and by giving it answers, by
saying this answer was right
or this answer was wrong.
So if you've never
heard of Joel Benjamin,
you've probably heard
of one of his students.
And one of his
students was Deep Blue.
Deep Blue was the IBM
computer that learned chess
from Joel Benjamin.
Joel is an expert
at chess, and IBM
hired him to help teach Deep
Blue how to play chess better
than any human.
Now if Joel Benjamin wasn't
better than every other human,
how did he teach that
computer to be better
than every other human?
It's because Deep Blue had
a much broader capacity.
So Mr. Benjamin could give
it all of the knowledge
through games.
Yes, if this happens,
this is what I would do.
If this happens, this
is what I would do.
So it's some level
of patterning,
but it's mostly
an expert system.
And in 1996, Deep Blue was
able to beat the human chess
champion.
And it was an amazing moment.
That was 1996.
20 years later, another product,
AlphaGo, using machine learning
was able to do something that
in 1996 everybody thought would
take many decades to achieve.
It took two decades.
That's a long time, but not that
long in the scheme of things.
And that is to beat a
champion Go player--
does anybody here
play the game Go?
OK, I respect you.
That is a hard game.
I don't play it.
It's a really hard game,
and it's very complex.
And I understand
why people thought,
no, a computer will
never beat a human at Go.
Very, very complex,
but that happened
in 2016, just this past year.
AlphaGo was the program that was
able to beat the human player.
And to give you an example
of the complexity increase
that happened from
1996 to 2016, I just
want to show you a visual.
So if you look at
the dot on the right
versus the dot on
the left, that's
the difference in complexity.
The dot on the left versus
the dot on the right
is the complexity difference
between the number
of moves in a game of chess
versus the number of moves
in a typical game of Go.
And that means the
dot on the left
doesn't even justify one
pixel on that big screen.
That's the difference
in the complexity.
To put it another way, if you
look at the number of moves
in a game of chess,
it equals the number
of atoms in the human body.
But if you look at the number of
moves in a typical game of Go,
it equals the number of
atoms in the universe.
That's the difference.
That's the leap that was taken
from '96 to 2016, 20 years.
And there are different
flavors of machine learning.
So this is just an understanding
of what machine learning means.
The first is
learning by example.
They call it
supervised learning.
So something like
a spam detector
trained on very simple examples
to say yes, this is spam.
No, this is not.
Yes this is spam.
And it's very, very effective
and is used in many machine
learning examples that
you see in your life,
including, if you use
Gmail, Gmail spam.
And it's pretty good.
Gmail spam detection
is pretty good.
The next is unsupervised
learning, which
is more like pattern discovery.
And it's very hard,
but it's clustering.
It's a method to cluster data,
like these things look similar.
These things look similar.
But if you don't have examples,
that's a good way to go.
And then the next one,
probably the hardest,
is reinforcement learning.
And that's feedback, but
after a long string of things.
And that's more like when
you win the game of chess,
and saying, OK, that long
string of moves that happened,
that worked.
And you have to look back
and understand why it worked.
So it's very slow.
A lot of people in
machine learning
would say that might actually
be the next big thing.
It might require the next leap
in capacity and capability.
And if you're really
interested in these models,
there's a ton of research
on research.google.com.
So just some examples--
speech recognition research.
Googlers who do this research
share a ton of it here.
And so pedestrian detection
for self-driving cars--
that's machine learning
because there's so
many patterns of
what a pedestrian is.
There's movement patterns,
there's shape patterns,
there's things that actually
require more than just saying,
oh, I recognize a human, because
humans come in many forms.
Things like natural
language understanding,
machine translation,
even advertising.
There's so much research there.
So if you're interested in the
topic, definitely go there.
Some of these examples--
I gave Gmail spam before.
It uses of what they call a
feed-forward neural network.
And it intercepts now
99.9% of all spam.
And every time you hit the
yes, this is spam button,
you're helping teach that model.
Thank you for doing that.
You keep my inbox clear of spam.
And I try to do
the same for you.
Speech recognition is another
example, taking acoustic input
and putting that through a
deeper current neural network
and getting the text output,
figuring out what that text is.
How many people here spoke
to their phone today?
Did you speak to your phone?
I do it almost every day now--
if nothing else, just for
a quick reply to an SMS
or something like that.
And reduced transcription
error is now--
or it is becoming
better and better.
Google Photo Search is one
of my favorite examples.
I try to be unbiased when I tell
people to use Google Photos.
It's really hard.
They don't believe
me that I'm unbiased.
But I truly believe it's one of
the best products you could use
if you care about your photos
and you take too many, which
we all do now.
I was much better
when I actually
had to print the photos and
get them in print at managing
sharing and things,
because I only took a few
and I shared those, and I
cared more about them, I think.
Now I just snap
millions of photos,
and I don't really look
back at them that much,
but I started to when I started
using Google Photo Search
because now I can look for
things that were not tagged
because it actually recognizes
patterns in the photos
through machine learning.
So this has improved my life.
So I can search now
for "beach," and it'll
find pictures of my
kids on the beach.
I didn't tag these.
I didn't do anything
to tag them,
but it can use machine learning
and the algorithms that
are there to do that for me.
Or "skiing"-- and I can find
pictures of my kids skiing.
so if I say to my mom, you got
to see your grandkids skiing,
I don't have to actually
think, oh let me go tag them
and whatever.
I just do a search and
I hand her my phone.
The other way it
improves our lives,
and maybe you guys will
recognize this, is--
anybody you know what that is?
Snapchat?
Otherwise known as
Snap at this point.
Did you buy the stock?
I didn't either.
But this improves
my life, right?
Now I can sit at
breakfast with my daughter
and have a lot of fun.
This is like literally--
I'm not kidding when I
say this improves my life.
I'm definitely laughing
more than I used to.
But it actually is
something that I appreciate,
but obviously it's not
improving my life necessarily.
It's entertainment.
But I will say
those same concepts
are improving human life.
And this is where I want to
make an association to learning.
This woman is Britney
Wenger, and in that picture
she's 17 years old, when
she won the Google Science
Fair for discovering an
incredibly effective method
of diagnosing breast cancer.
And she did that by learning
coding, machine learning,
big data, and big
data analysis, tools
that were not taught in school.
But she took it
upon herself, not
because she wanted to
win the science fair,
but because she wanted
to improve life.
And that's truly impactful, a
little bit more than Snapchat.
So we've done an amazing job
teaching machines, really
amazing job, and it has
helped us as humans.
But what about humans?
How has learning changed
over those 20 years?
We saw how much it's
changed, and who
knows what it's going to
do over the next 20 years?
Somebody asked me today, do you
think your 10-year-old daughter
will get a driver's license?
And of course at first I'm
thinking, why wouldn't she?
And then I realized
what he was asking
me was will she need to drive?
Or will self-driving
cars be the norm?
If they're truly better,
why are we driving?
And he's in San
Francisco, and he said,
you ever notice how
many cars are parked
on both sides of every street?
Imagine if that wasn't so.
Imagine all the
room we would gain.
Imagine the efficiency.
Imagine the change in pollution.
Everything changes,
when you think about it,
if humans don't have to drive,
park, do all those things.
And literally the accident rate
goes way down because humans
are really bad drivers.
We don't set a high bar for
machines, let's just say.
But if you compare human
learning to machine
learning, and this is just a
visual, not necessarily fact.
I don't have numbers
to prove this chart.
But where have we
gone in 20 years?
How have we changed
learning in 20 years?
I think it's improved, but it
has not improved or changed
enough.
And it has not improved greatly.
it's not noticeable.
I can't really show it.
There are instances I can show.
I've seen amazing
educational instances--
people, situations,
classes, methods.
But they feel like
they're spot changes.
And where is that
graph going to go?
How are we going to
change that graph?
I want to give you
an example that I
feel really proves
the point of something
that I think is
wrong with education.
This is a math problem.
There are 26 goats and
10 sheep on a boat.
And the question that's
asked is, how old
is the captain of the boat?
This was a question asked
in the study of a bunch
of fifth graders not long ago.
75% of the fifth graders
asked gave a numeric answer
to this question.
They actually
answered the question.
They tried to answer it.
Sometimes I like to give away a
Jamboard or something to person
anybody who can get the answer.
Because I don't think
there is an answer.
These are the answers
the kids gave, though.
75 percent, most of
them, gave the answer 36.
[LAUGHTER]
Clearly the captain
of the boat is 36.
And you know why?
Because I have two numbers.
When they were asked, why do
you think the captain is 36?
Well, in these
types of problems,
we usually have to
add the two numbers.
16 is another answer they give.
You know, sometimes
it's tricky, and you've
got to subtract them.
And then there was one
or two instances of 260,
where they're doing
advanced math and thinking,
well, I might not have
learned that in school
yet, but multiplication--
I can do this.
But this is the proof, right?
They're programed.
This is the irony.
Our kids are programmed, even
though they haven't really
advanced as much as
machines have improved
in their learning, because we
teach them with rote methods.
We teach them to do
things in rote ways.
Follow steps, not
solve problems,
and not to understand.
And what can we do
to help solve that?
What are some of the things?
And these are some basic things.
But first of all, we could
help train teachers more,
give them the tools.
Some of this happens
because teachers
are teaching the way they
were taught to teach.
And our teaching
programs haven't really
changed that much,
or haven't changed
enough to include
today's tools, new tools,
new ways of teaching.
And giving children and
students and people--
this is not just about kids--
experiences, not just facts.
Let's let them
experience something.
Like I said before, with
some of the data model,
the machine learning, we're
giving the machine experiences,
saying try this.
Oh, fail.
OK, now we told you it failed.
Try again.
Success!
Try again, fail.
Try again, success.
You can't get that necessarily
unless you have experiences.
And there are methods
of giving experiences.
I even show Google
Expeditions here.
It's a precursor to
something I'll show later.
And experts help, too.
Connect experts with
students, with learners.
Let them experience with
that expert has experienced.
And I show basically Hangout,
Skype, Twitter as examples
of the technology that's there
to help with experiences.
Sometimes it's just
social networks.
Like, sure, they're
useful in some ways.
But they're useful to
connect you to experts.
And educators can actually
reach out on those networks
to find experts when
they are not the expert.
The teacher just has to be
the guide, not the expert.
And games can help, too.
Games help a tremendous amount
because they motivate learning.
They help to motivate learning
for everyone, not just
students.
And I just have a quick example.
I have a friend
who's a driver who's
not so good at driving, one
of these examples of setting
a low bar.
But then she got a
Prius, and the Prius
gives immediate
feedback and a score.
And as soon as you see a
score, everything changes.
I want a better score.
Slow down.
OK, I slow down, I
get a better score.
Oh my gosh, I'm learning.
And it happens immediately.
I actually did this
in my car recently.
I just changed what
my dashboard would
show to show my efficiency,
my fuel efficiency,
and it's a gas
car, unfortunately.
But I found myself
driving so well.
I was so careful to
not accelerate too much
and to not necessarily
overuse the brake.
And that means I'm going to keep
a bigger distance because then
I can be more efficient.
And I started playing a game
to see how high I could get
my miles per gallon efficiency.
And not only was it fun,
but the people in the car
were like, wow, you're
driving so carefully.
What happened?
And it really was
an obvious change.
And then my son, I talked to
him from where I was driving to,
and he said, what
was the efficiency?
What was your score
on the way down?
He even cared.
It was just a game
because it was fun.
And grades could reflect just
learning, not everything else.
So it is important to know
if you're right or wrong.
We said experiences
are important.
And to know whether
or not it was
the right answer
or wrong answer,
sometimes it is important
to get that feedback.
But we so often incorporate
everything else into a grade
that we give to a student.
It's like what happened?
I thought you really
knew your chemistry.
Well, I was late on
three assignments.
It's like, oh, so
we don't really
know if you learned chemistry.
No.
Well, that's a pity.
Oh and I was late four days.
I had an A+, but I was late
four days, so I got a B.
There's a good idea.
So what are we doing in
learning technology today?
And I would say learning
technology today has been
focused, and there
are some instances
that this is not true, and
they are more advanced.
They're just not there enough.
They're not everywhere.
But what we're doing
generally in learning today
is focusing on the basics.
So one thing we know
is amazing in education
is immediate feedback.
Teacher-student feedback
is so important.
That's why we saw
something like Docs,
and why I started with that
being so impactful for teachers
because they realized they could
give immediate feedback to 100
students without being there.
But what was frustrating them
was the ability to share.
And that's actually
why-- in other words,
they have 100 students.
How do I share to 100
students and get that feedback
to 100 students quickly?
And it was super hard.
That's why we created Classroom.
Google Classroom was created
on that foundation to say,
if we could get
them there faster,
they'll be better teachers.
They'll be happier.
They'll spend more
time with students,
and they won't be
so inefficient.
We tried to get them off paper
and onto something that was
easy to give feedback faster.
Same thing with field trips.
Field trips are
amazing experiences.
It's the kind of thing that
when you look back at school,
and you think about
what your remembered,
field trips are memorable.
And it's not just the noisy bus.
That's memorable in a bad way.
But it's incredibly enriching.
You really feel it.
And there is some
proof and research
that shows that when
your body is involved,
when your senses are
involved, you remember more,
you learn more.
You're open to learning.
But what's frustrating
about that is it's
hard to go on field
trips, really hard.
They're expensive.
Not every kid has the
same opportunities.
I've seen in my
own schools, we've
cut back on field trips for cost
and just for access reasons.
You don't have enough
children participating,
so you can't really do it.
And you're usually limited
to where your bus can go,
even if it's a three-hour ride.
And that's why we created
Google Expeditions specifically
out of the team that's
focused on education,
so that we could at least try to
give children more experiences
using virtual reality.
And now it's easy to argue
that that's not the same,
but it's pretty good.
And we know it's pretty
good because we've
tried it in hundreds and
hundreds of classrooms.
And especially, even
before we launched it,
we tried it with some
teachers and students,
and invariably the
experience was amazing
and the engagement
was super high.
And when we combine that
with good lesson planning,
it's really taking off in a
way that is great for students
and great for teachers.
And there's hundreds
and hundreds
of expeditions now being used in
classrooms as part of lessons,
and the children are
experiencing more.
They can go to Rome.
They can go to the
Great Wall of China.
And it can be for a math class,
not just a history class.
It's not just about
getting to that place.
It's about learning
using that place.
Whiteboards-- and it's funny
because I never really made
this connection until I
saw what was happening,
but whiteboards
could be amazing.
But again, there's things
that would protect the teacher
from using it in the way we
would like to see them use it.
There's no save or
recall, no sharing.
You can't add imagery
necessarily to a white board,
unless you're an
incredible artist.
It's not legible.
You've got ink and all
the things that go wrong.
So we produced Jamboard.
That was really for a
business environment,
but we're seeing and
learning obviously,
and this is not a
new concept, it's
something that really enhances
learning if you can use it
the way it should be used.
And that's what we're doing
in learning technology.
But what could we do
if we really focused?
What could we do to enhance
learning using technology
and advanced technology?
First of all, there's an
incredible number of tools.
I mentioned Brittany Wenger,
who's now a researcher.
I think she's still
with Georgia Tech,
but now a researcher, a medical
researcher in her 20s now.
So it was I think it was 2012
that she won the science fair,
if you want to look that up.
But there are tools
out there now,
and you saw probably
some of them
announced today and
produced even before today.
TensorFlow, natural language
APIs, big cloud data,
analytics, Vision API
to pull information out
of videos, something that
would take just forever
if you had to do it manually.
And maybe there's
many things that
can be done if students are
taught some of these tools.
And if you're thinking, yeah,
but what student could actually
learn those tools?
Isn't that too advanced?
The answer is no, they're
not too advanced anymore.
The bar for using those
tools has come way down.
And what we often
do is we project
what we feel is our own
limitation on our students.
And we think, wow,
I don't get that.
That doesn't mean the
student won't get it.
I found that my 16-year-old
learns much faster than I do.
And he'll get things
before me now.
And I actually
remember that moment
with my dad, when he was
frustrated with me passing him
in my ability to do things.
And it always made me
feel good to teach him.
And now I'm lucky
because I feel good when
my son is able to teach me.
But we have to give them the
benefit of the doubt, which
means letting them learn things
that are more advanced than we
knew and what we were taught.
What we learned in
school is not what
we should be teaching
our students in school.
It's just not the same thing.
And unfortunately, that's
not where we are today.
We're basically teaching
them what we were taught.
So these tools are
actually useful.
And imagine how many
Brittany Wengers we
could have if we taught
everyone those tools
that she had to go
learn on her own.
She had to even know
they were available.
One of the things we
could do with those tools
is match learning
to the learner.
I like to say if you've
seen one student,
you've seen one student, but
we teach them all the same.
And I know that's not
true in every case.
Sometimes there are breakouts.
There is a way to group
children or give them
personalized learning
with some tools.
There are some amazing
tools out there.
Like I said, they're just
not pervasive enough.
But we could do a lot more
if we'd collect the data.
So first we have to recognize
what data should we collect,
and then we have to say, what
can we do with that data?
But this is one thing that we
can make incredible advances
on if we really focus.
And there's three
areas that I would
say you could match the
learning to the learner.
First is the content.
What are you actually
using to teach?
Then the format.
How is it delivered?
Is it physical?
You're out in the field.
Or is it video,
or is it reading?
I know myself and my wife, we
learn in very different ways.
She's a reader, and
I lose consciousness
when I read basically.
I'm a visual learner.
And the pace, the pace
is always different.
But a slow-paced learner
is not a worse learner.
They are just a
slower-paced learner.
They might absorb more.
The other thing we
could do is provide
more immediate feedback.
And here I want to give
you an example of something
that actually exists.
It was launched very recently.
And I just took a few
screen shots, just earlier
today, to show what
can be done with this.
It's called the Perspective API.
And when you leave here today,
or if you have your laptop
and you're really
bored, you can actually
go to the Perspective
API and try this.
There's a lot of things
you can try there.
One of the things you can
try struck me immediately
as something that
can be applied,
and not just
education generally,
but specifically
educating people,
and especially students, how to
communicate more effectively.
What could be more
important than helping
us communicate more
effectively with each other?
How often do you think, wow,
I can't deal with that person.
Or that was such a
tough discussion.
Or, wow, did you see that email?
Can you believe that?
I can't believe that
was the response.
Or the reply all that
you wish the person could
read before they sent.
The Perspective API was
launched out of the Jigsaw team
at Google.
And Jigsaw used to be called
the Google Ideas team.
And they have very high
I would say aspirations
to help humanity, literally.
And one of the things
they were trying to do
is reduce toxicity
in communication.
And so if immediately
you're thinking,
oh, you mean YouTube comments?
You're actually right.
That's one of the things that
they actually tested it on.
But others, like the New
York Times and Wikipedia,
they tried it.
And they tried to train that
model to measure toxicity.
And they have a
tool online that I
would love to see wired to
every communication method
that we use, even Snapchat.
And I'll give you an example.
If I said, "you are so stupid"
in response to somebody,
that gets a 97%
toxicity rating--
97%.
But I bet that
comment is out there
in the ether a million times.
You are so stupid.
And basically it's saying
97% similar to comments
people said were toxic.
So they had people, just
like the spam thing,
say yep, toxic, toxic,
toxic, not so toxic.
You know, how would
you rate this?
And that model was
trained against this data.
If I just change that to "that
is so stupid," not you, that,
it goes down a little bit--
94 percent.
All right, not quite enough.
I should be a little
less toxic still.
But if I change it again
to say "that is so dumb,"
now that gets a 76%
toxicity rating.
I'm learning.
I'm learning to be less toxic.
And then if I
change that to say,
"that might be a bad idea,"
that goes down to 12%.
And if I go even further and say
I want to be even less toxic,
I say "that is not
a great idea,"--
2%.
Send.
Imagine if every student,
instead of saying, no,
you cannot use chat, or
you cannot use email--
how many schools
shut down email?
They say no, the students
can't send email.
They can't talk to
each other on email.
A lot of schools, if you're
not involved in education,
a lot of schools basically
say, we don't actually
give our kids email at school,
especially in the younger
grades.
But imagine if we did
and we helped them learn
how to communicate better.
How many bad adult
communications
could you avoid in the future?
So that's just an
idea of something
you can do with Perspective API.
And there's so many
other things out there
that you could do that with.
There are so many
other applications.
And if you think through some
of the things that are announced
here or at the next industry API
conference or machine learning
conference, there
are so many ways
you can look at those
things and say, how can we
use that in education?
How could a learner use that?
And I would compel you to
do that because there's also
opportunity there.
But if I look at
learning technology,
I like to think
of it as there is
the now, learning technology,
and that's where we've been.
So providing
engaging experiences,
reducing teaching
friction, and relevance
for students futures--
in other words,
learning technology, the
stuff that we use to learn,
is relevant because
kids will use it.
If you look at the verb
learning technology,
you want to learn technology,
which also means teach
technology, if teachers
model modern practices,
students will learn it better.
If they see a teacher handing
out paper, collecting paper,
and taking a week
to give feedback,
that is not a good model
for a student to think, oh,
that's how it works.
No it doesn't.
It doesn't work
like that at all.
And if they're forced to sit
there, every single student,
and learn cursive
writing, and feel
free to come up here and
attack me later about cursive
writing if you want,
I'll argue till I'm done.
Every single student
learning cursive writing--
I would argue that
that's not necessarily
relevant to their future.
It might be if
they're an artist.
But teachers modeling
modern practice
is important for
learning technology.
In other words, learn it.
And discovering advanced tools--
learn it.
Learn those tools.
Teach those tools.
And then learning how to
apply that technology.
How should I use it?
Using relevant
examples and saying,
this is how we use
this technology.
I want my kids to
learn spreadsheets
in the third grade or the second
grade so that they understand,
oh, yeah, that's
how you do that.
That's how you actually--
first of all,
that's what data is.
They don't even know
what data is usually
when they get to, say,
the ninth grade sometimes.
And it doesn't matter
what tool they use.
If they really want to
use Excel, I'll allow it.
But if they want to use Google
Spreadsheets, I'd be happier.
But I'm just giving
them as an example.
Spreadsheets are super
useful in our lives.
They should learn it
super early, and they can.
Trust me, I've seen it.
First graders, second graders,
third graders learning
spreadsheets is totally doable.
And that's just one
example, a simple one,
but learning how to apply it.
But I would say you
go to the next level.
And what we're at today,
what we're trying to do,
is improve and just
make learning better.
And to get better learning,
we take those two things
and we go to the
next step and just
basically focus on learning
to solve unknown problems,
not learning to follow the
examples of our predecessors
that solve problems
and say, oh, yeah,
this is how this
problem was solved.
Follow these steps.
Learn these steps.
Maybe there's a
new way to do it.
And learning to learn--
figuring out what do you do
when you don't know something.
And trying not to just answer
students with, oh, here's
the answer.
This is the answer.
No.
Here's how you go about
finding an answer.
So if we don't
allow our students
to use their phones
in school, they
don't know that they could look
for that answer much quicker
much more quickly.
And they don't know
that that's just
a fact that they could look up.
Why don't we let them do that?
We find value in them
memorizing that fact instead?
I don't.
So I want to see us
teaching students to learn.
And I'll end it there.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]